[Music]
Well, hello dear friends. Welcome to the
program I'd like to know. This is a
question and answer program where you
send us your questions. We do the
research and then we answer to the best
of our ability the questions that you
ask. Let me give you the address of
where you can send the questions. You'll
see it on the screen. It's
tvsumtv.org. Once again,
tvsumtv.org. I have with me uh two
individuals that uh I know very well.
They work at Secrets Unsealed. It's
wonderful to work with both of them. I
have to my right, to your left, CA
Murray, who is wearing some new glasses,
which makes him look very dignified. And
on my left, we have Daniel Miranda, who
is one of our newer additions. He's
going to be spearheading the Spanish
work here at Secrets Unsealed. Uh we've
been longing for that to happen. I have
been at least for a long time. And uh
welcome. We're glad that you're here.
Thank you, Pastor. And uh we always want
to pray before we start uh doing
anything regarding the Bible. And so I
am going to ask uh that uh you would uh
have a word of prayer. Shall we pray?
Father God, we know that spiritual
things are spiritually discerned. So we
ask now for the mind of Christ. Amen. So
that we may under the oposes of his holy
spirit go to your word and mind the
truths that are there. Yes. and then
give correct biblical answers for the
questions that are asked. Amen. We know,
we understand that uh we don't need to
give man's opinion. We need to hear a
word from the Lord. So we ask and we
thank you for your promise to hear and
answer the prayer of faith as prayed in
the name of Jesus. Amen. Amen. Okay,
Daniel, I think that we have a very
interesting question that I don't really
have the answer for, but I know someone
here who does. Yeah. So, what's the
question? So we have a question here.
This question was sent um there is not a
name here but it says hi pastor bore.
What is the origin
and of the black Hebrew Israelite
belief? What is the Bible basis?
All right. Uh I guess that question
falls to me gentlemen. And um there are
a number of ways to to deal with that
particular question. Um and a number of
things that we can we can take a look
at.
Um we can look at it from the sort of
macro view and from the the micro
view. There is no basis in the Bible for
anything except true Bible religion.
Amen. Amen.
uh the religion for these days since the
death of Christ is called
Christianity. Those people who have
ascend assembled themselves, who have
called themselves out, who want to be
like
Christ, the the black Hebrew religion
goes back to the late 1800s, the 19th
century. It is neither truly Hebrew nor
is it truly Christian. It is sort of a
hybrid kind of faith. There were in in
the 1800s any number of faiths. I did a
sermon some time ago called muddy
waters. And I looked at the the
emergence of a number of faiths that
began in the mid late 1800s around 1844
when Christ was doing his work in in
moving from holy to most holy place.
Satan put up uh in the minds of many
people a number of large number of
faiths. There were uh a number of
utopian societies and these were
societies that tried to take the place
of true religion. Man trying to engineer
uh a millennium here on planet earth. In
the 1840s alone, 80 80 utopian societies
were uh sprung up and started. The the
black Hebrew religion in the broadest
context is in the context of those
utopian societies. It it came so late.
It came really about 1888 uh
1886 because in the 1840s when most of
the other uh utopian societies were were
being started, blacks of course were not
free to start anything. Um they couldn't
do anything till
after emancipation proclamation and
reconstruction. Uh so uh the black
utopian movement, if I can say that,
really began about 40 years later after
the uh white utopian movements began,
but it's in the same train. And the the
black Hebrew movement is is sort of like
that. When you look up the principal
names, you see Frank Cherry, William
Saunders Crowy, and uh Wentworth Arthur
Matthews. These are the men who sort of
began. And if you if you look up one
thing about any anybody can become a
scholar with Google. So if you Google
those names, you can become a scholar on
the black Hebrew movement. It's not a
centralized movement. It's like the
general conference. We have a general
conference that's the the the central
body of the seventh adventist church.
This is much more amorphous,
congregational uh in structure. So
you've had churches here, churches
there. They don't all believe precisely
the same thing. um even though they are
called black Hebrews, if you look at
some of the rhetoric, some of the
rhetoric actually is racist and
anti-semitic uh to tell the truth. It's
it's not all uh as it should be. So
given that framework, then it's not
really Christian because Christ was not
a racist. Christians are not racist and
Christians certainly are not
anti-Semitic. So you've got this this
sort of amorphous group. They believe a
lot of things. The founders believed
that the Lord told them that
African-Americans were part of a lost
Hebrew tribe and that is their
connection to Judaism or
Hebrewism but their doctrines are vastly
different. So it does exist at its top
you had maybe 40,000 uh it is splintered
and splintered again and splintered a
third time and splintered a fourth time.
So the numbers are not quite sure but it
it does exist. It is not a very uh fast
growing movement. It doesn't have a lot
of political clout. Uh it will never I
think grow into anything because it is
so amorphous. It is congregational. Now
I need to say this gentlemen.
All of the mainline Protestant
denominations and many of the smaller
ones have had to deal with um the idea
of racism and slavery. All of them. Uh
all of them have had to struggle with
this. the Methodist church split from
the United Methodists to the AMES, the
African Methodists, AM Zion, which is
the African Methodist Episcopal Zion
Church in New York City. Um, the
Methodist church split over its bishops
holding slaves. Uh, the Presbyterian
Church, the Baptist Church, the
Adventist church have all had to deal
with what are we going to do with the
black issue. Mhm. Um Ellen White gave
gave very pointed counsel that the
church was in time not doing what it
should have uh done. We haven't always
been successful. The the emergence of
black conferences in the mid 1940s was a
response to uh the black constituency
feeling that they could not get a just
hearing in the halls of Adventism. And
of course, the L
uh Louisa Bayard incident where a very
fairkinned black woman was brought into
Washington Advent Hospital when it was
found out that she was black. She was
wheeled out into the hall and of course
she died. Well, then the brethren said,
"Okay, we're going to start our own our
own black conferences." Um, so you've
got a number of things. We haven't
always been at our best when it when it
comes to racial ins. I I know of
individuals who uh were in the general
conference in the 1930s and 1940s. they
are all dead now. Uh where blacks had to
eat at their desks because they couldn't
eat in a general conference cafeteria.
So we've had the same problems that
every church has had that the United
States has had. Luckily, we are doing a
whole heap better than we were back in
the day. But um Ellen White sort of lets
us know that these racial antagonisms
will be around until Christ comes
because man's heart is evil and man's
heart is hard and uh so we've got to
wrestle with this. So we've got we've
got a fair share of problems of which
race is one. It is a big one but it is
just one. There are several. So when we
look at uh the black Hebrew movement
it's around um you may find some
churches here some churches there they
are not very very large uh and their
doctrines are not one thing I love about
the Adventist church. If I go to the
Philippines, if I go to Australia, if I
go to Russia, I will hear pretty much
the same doctrinal package that I preach
every Sabbath in my church. Um because
we are unified. Well, when you go to
Brack Hebrew churches, you're not going
to find the same set of beliefs. They're
going to vary a little bit because the
churches are congregational. They are
independent. So, that's pretty much it.
Um, there's a lot we could say about
what Satan was doing in the uh 1800s,
starting all of these false churches.
All of them had the same sort of look as
the Adventist Church. Many of them
started by a woman. And I I've got, you
know, uh, Anna Lee with the Shakers and
Mary Baker Eddie with Christian
Sciences, Katherine Booth, Salvation
Army. Uh, so they look like the
Adventist Church in their structure
started by a female prophet. Uh, all of
those kind of things, but they weren't
true. It was Satan's smokeokc screen,
dare I say, trying to to keep people's
mind off what Christ was doing. And of
course, you had the Seventh Day
Adventist Church, which is now 21
million plus members and a worldwide
church in all of the countries. uh and
we can see the hand of God and we can
proudly say these are three men who are
part of the seventh day adventist
church. Our membership is in the seventh
day adventist church and though secrets
on sale is not run by the seventh day
adventist church it is a supporting
ministry we preach the advent message we
are Adventists through and through and
we thank the Lord for it. Amen. So I
guess the short answer is uh because the
question is what is the Bible basis for
this? The answer is there is no biblical
basis. Yeah. And I I want I thought I
said up front that there is no biblical
basis um for for this. It was started by
a group of men who came up with an idea.
Little bit of Judaism, little bit of
Christianity, not really Christian, not
really Jew. And of course, if if you're
not allin with Christ, then you're not
biblically based because Christ accepts
nothing less than our very best and our
all. Amen. Amen. All right, Daniel.
Well, I think that the answer is pretty
clear. Um, we have another question here
from Ailen
Lucen and this question says, "Blessings
to you all at Secrets Unseal. I was
listening to some of your sermons
speaking to Pastor Boore and classes and
perhaps with the Holy Spirit speaking to
me, it hit me that if you check out each
part of the armor in Ephesians 6, each
part is a reference to Christ." Have you
ever had or done a sermon about that? I
would love to watch it. Thank you,
pastor world, pastor Bore as well as the
other pastors when they are there.
Well, you know, the interesting thing is
that um she probably was
listening, she actually says that she
was listening and uh this question came
to her mind and uh she was probably
listening to one of my audio sermons
that I did at Fresno Central Church uh a
couple of decades ago.
And um and so this uh question really
hit me. He said, "Hey, you know,
somebody listened to that sermon." Uh
the answer is that um yes, each part of
the armor of Ephesians chapter 6 uh has
Jesus Christ at the center. And I'll
just mention I'll just mention this
quickly because we don't have time to
read all of the verses. But uh it
mentions there in Ephesians 6, the
breastplate of righteousness. And in
Jeremiah 23:6, it says, "The Lord our
righteousness," referring to Jesus
Christ. Yes. In fact, uh Isaiah 59:17, a
messianic prophecy speaks about the
Messiah having a breastplate of
righteousness. Uh then you have the
waist, uh girded with
truth. And of course, we know John 14
and verse 6, Jesus says, "I am the way,
the truth, and the life." And then you
have the feet uh with the gospel of
peace. Well, who is the prince of peace?
Jesus is the prince of peace. Um, the
shield of
faith. Well, you know the shield of
faith. We need to have the faith of
whom? Here's the patience of the saints,
those who keep the commands commandments
of God and the faith of faith of Jesus.
Amen. Then it mentions the helmet of
salvation which is source is Isaiah
59:17 where it says that the Messiah
would have the helmet of salvation. Yes.
And then you have the sword of the
spirit. which by the way is the only
offensive weapon in this list. And uh
the sword of the spirit represents the
word that comes from the mouth of Jesus
and uh is uh written in the hearts
through the holy spirit uh because Jesus
comes with a sword coming out of his
mouth which is his word. So every part
of the of the armor is really uh an
aspect of Christ. And what brings it all
together? Uh if we could have maybe u ca
if you would read Romans chapter
13. Romans chapter 13 and verses 11 to
14. It brings everything together
beautifully because it's going to say
that that the armor when we cover
ourselves with the armor it's covering
ourselves with Christ. Yeah. So, let's
uh let's read then uh Romans chapter uh
13 and verse 11. Yeah, this is one of my
favorite texts. And do this. Knowing the
time that now it is high time to awake
out of sleep. For now our salvation is
nearer than when we first believed. The
night is far spent. The day is at hand.
Therefore, let us cast off the works of
darkness, and let us put on the armor of
light. And 13. Do you want 13 through
through 14? Okay.
Let us walk properly as in the day, not
in revery or and drunkenness, not in
lwdness and lust, not in strife and
envy, but put on the Lord Jesus Christ
and make no provision for the flesh to
fulfill its lust. So when you compare
verse 12, verse 12 says, "Let us put on
the armor of light." And then at the end
it says, "Put on Jesus." put on the Lord
Jesus Christ. So, every part of the
armor, yes, is some aspect of Christ.
And when we have all those aspects,
we're covered with the armor. So, um I
hope that that answers the question.
Eileen, thank you for listening to a
sermon that I preached a long time ago,
which I've never done at Secrets
Unsealed.
Okay. What is the next question that we
have, CA? Um there's a little longer
question here. Is this the one on um
from David? Yep. David Jones. David
Jones. Okay. I think my question may
require you to speculate a bit because
as far as I can tell it uh the Bible
doesn't really answer it. My question is
where was Jesus when the woman got to
the tomb on Sunday morning? Later he
appeared to Mary at the tomb and late in
the day he appeared to the two disciples
on the road to Emmas and after that he
appeared to the 11 and others but I
don't see anywhere where it mentions
where Jesus went immediately after he
resurrected. There is an answer to that.
Uh we know that he hadn't gone to heaven
yet because he asked Mary not to cling
to him, not to delay him because he had
not yet ascended. But where was he when
the woman arrived and discovered the
empty tomb? I think that Jesus must have
met with the others who were resurrected
prior to them going to into the city.
But I am just speculating. Perhaps there
is something I missed or maybe you know
of something Ellen White wrote that
could answer my question. All right. So,
who wants to tackle this one?
Well, when
we go to the Desire of Ages, uh Ellen
White gives us the answer there pretty
clearly. It's in page
790 of Desire of Ages. Um this she's
commenting this the the verse that she's
quoting. Jesus refused to receive the
homage of his people until he had the
assurance that his sacrifice was
accepted by the father. So let us
remember that Jesus had to fulfill the
the feast on their time and this Sunday
corresponds to the first fruits. So it
was necessary for Jesus himself being
the first fruit to appear before the
father. um he ascended to the heavenly
courts and from God himself heard the
assurance that his atonement for the
sins of men had been ample that through
his blood all might gain eternal life.
So she says here clearly that he
ascended to uh the presence of the
father and then um next paragraph it
says while the savior was in god's
presence receiving gifts for his church
the disciples thought upon his empty
tomb and mourned and wept. We know from
the records of the gospels that he came
back and he presented to his disciples
and spent with them 40 days after this.
So Jesus resurrects. Um you know
something interesting is mentioned here
that I hadn't thought about before and
that is that maybe Jesus met those who
resurrected with him to give them
instructions on what to do. That kind of
even though it's speculation, it kind of
makes sense because you know all these
people resurrected uh they would have
had to know known that Jesus had
resurrected and that they were supposed
to go to the city to give witness to
him. Yes, I would assume. It's
interesting. I when I first read the the
uh question, I I took it as Daniel did.
Um uh I've got desire to seven 790 right
here. You know, the exact same quote.
But I think he's saying even before Mary
came between any time he came out of the
tomb that interr before she got there
what was he doing then right and the
Bible is is silent but it is not I don't
think it does violence to the thought of
scripture to think that maybe he gave
him a little pep talk before uh you know
before he sent him in just like Moses re
re uh uh reaffirmed the commandments
before the children went in of to
Israel. Maybe the Lord, this is a brand
new group. They're going to a new
experience. Maybe spend a little time
with them. The Bible is silent. It it
wasn't very long. We know he came up and
dawn came and he uh they were there and
they got there just before dawn. So, we
don't know how long a period of time
that was. It couldn't have been too
long. But uh that is not uh untoward to
think that. I think Yeah. Well, Jesus
actually appeared before his father in
heaven at about nine o'clock in the
morning. And you see that in Acts
chapter 2 and verse 13 where you know
because uh the day of Pentecost was
exactly 50 days after the resurrection.
Yes. And so uh and you know when they
when the people were speaking in tongues
uh the enemy said ah you know they're
just drunk. And Peter says how are they
drunk if it's only a third hour of the
day. Right. And so uh so he ascended um
sometime after he resurrected. Uh but
you know for me um it doesn't make sense
that all these individuals resurrected
in many different places and that uh you
know how would they know what to do?
They would have had to have met with
Jesus and Jesus given them like you said
a pep talk. You know go to the city and
let people know that uh that I've
resurrected. And um you know it's an an
amazing thought that uh that among this
group uh were the Ellen White identifies
them as martyrs from the first the ones
who first lived which would probably be
Abel and Abel was more than twice as
tall as the normal human beings. Yes. I
guess I should say normal because the
normal ones are back there. The abnormal
ones are the ones that were affected by
sin. Uh but you know it's I I even
though I don't have a thus sayaith the
Lord, it makes sense that Jesus would
have met with them for a while and given
them instructions. Yeah, they and and
they weren't all buried in the same
place. And and that's a good point.
Christ came up u uh in the garden in the
tomb, but they were everywhere. So to
get them together to kind of speak with
them, give him a little pep talk. You're
going to a brand new experience now. Uh
that's not untoward. I I in fact I like
that idea. Makes you feel kind of good.
Unless before they died, an angel said,
"You know, you're going to resurrect
when Jesus resurrects, so go and
announce it." That's the other
possibility. But there had to be a
meeting.
So anyway, well, that's a interesting
academic question. Yeah, it's a fun. We
can ask Jesus when we get to heaven.
Sure. Put it on the list. He'll give us
the the the true answer. I got a few
more I want to ask him before that, but
I I'll get to this one, too. Yeah, it's
a curiosity indeed. Uh, okay. Uh, we
have another question. This one is sent
by Ron Man. We get lots of questions
from Ron Man. Indeed. Uh so do you have
that one, Daniel? Yes, I do. Want to
read that for us, please? Sure.
So, the question has to do with the
parable of the talents um in the one
found in Matthew
25:14-30 and Luke 19:11-27.
Um, so the question is with the account
in Luke involving the good productive
servants being out in charge of many
cities and with the evil servant being
dealt a judgment that seems to be the
basis of the third angel's message. Mark
of the beast judgment scene of
Revelation 14 9-10. The question is two
part. How do we reconcile or explain
these different additional details? And
the second question is, is there
actually an end time prophetic dimension
to this parable pointedly in regards to
Luke's city's rule appointments and also
the seeming third angel's message
illusion basis.
Okay. Um I might just mention that um
these two parables are similar but not
identical as Ron man mentions. Um but
they they are two different parables.
Mhm. They're similar, but they're two
different parables. Uh so, you know, we
would expect a variation in details
depending on the emphasis that Jesus
wanted to give. Uh it's kind of like the
feeding of the 4,000 and the feeding of
the 5,000. You know, uh people say,
well, you know, there's a discrepancy
between the the gospels because one says
it was 4,000, the other says it's 5,000.
Ellen White makes it clear that they
were two different feedings. Precisely.
Uh and so you know the fact that you
have Matthew
25:14-30 which is the parable of the
talents and uh Luke 19:11-27 which is of
the minus uh and their variation of
details uh would indicate that the these
are two different parables that Jesus
told at different occasions for
different purposes. Uh but um in terms
of the end time dimension
u any thoughts on that? Well, I see a
just a basic difference and I think um
has to do with the emphasis the one in
Matthew 25. Uh the emphasis in is in
more in the our faithfulness to the
talents that God has given us and the
reward that we receive. And now in Luke
we also see the same emphasis but then
Luke adds um that that that reward we do
not only receive it here but in heaven.
In other words, uh our position in
heaven is determined by our faithfulness
here on earth with the talents with the
use of the talents that God has given us
to to some is given 10 cities to rule.
uh there will be I just remember I don't
bring I didn't bring the quote here with
me but Ellen White speaks of eternal
eternal loss that there will be some
people who will be saved and yet because
they didn't make a right use of their
talents here they will experience an
eternal loss that they won't be as close
or or to Jesus or not as close but not
in the place that Jesus would have them
in heaven because they um didn't take
advantage of the opportunities given to
them on earth. That's an amazing
thought, isn't it? It is. It is. That we
can make decisions here now that even
though we are saved will will still
affect us throughout all all eternity.
Now, of course, heaven is such a place
where there's no jealousy, there's no
I'm looking on your plate to see what
you got, I'm looking his plate. So, that
that aspect is not there. But there will
be some differentiation because of
decisions we made here on earth while we
were here. Right? You know there's one
thing here in the parable of the miners
which is not directly contained in the
parable of the talents although it's
it's hinted at uh you know where where
the servants are called to render an
account for what they received. Uh but
in verse 12 of Luke chapter 19 uh we
have the idea that Jesus receives the
kingdom in heaven before he returns.
Mhm. It goes to the father to receive
the kingdom. And that that requires a
judgment to see who is a member of his
kingdom. Correct. Uh it says there in
verse 12, therefore he said a certain
nobleman, yes, went into a far country.
That nobleman of course would be Christ
who went into a far country, heaven, to
receive for himself a kingdom and then
to return. So Jesus receives the kingdom
in heaven before he returns. And I think
that might be the esqueological uh
dimension of this particular parable.
Correct. Yes. Yes. Yes. So anyway, we
have just a few seconds remaining. Any
final thoughts on this uh particular
question? We have just 50 seconds left.
Well, we see two groups of people saved
in heaven in or in the new earth after
the millennium. We see those who are in
the city with Jesus Christ and those who
will come every Sabbath day and every
month to worship before the Lord. And as
there were Jesus had his 12 12 disciples
but John was the closest to him. Those
who are more faithful here on earth who
love him most will be closest to Jesus
in heaven. Praise the Lord. Everything
we do now has an esquetological bent and
view. Right? Everything we do, we do for
now, but we also do for eternity. I, you
know, we talk about these little things.
I don't really care. I just want to get
in. I say that sincerely. You got a big
crown. I got a small crown. I got a
crown. You got a crown. That's all I
want to say. Well, thank you for joining
us. Our time is up. Come and be with us
the next time. God bless.
[Music]